[Música]
punto final a una negociación tortuosa
lenta que generaba muchísima expectativa
por fin Londres y Bruselas alcanzaron un
acuerdo sobre el polémico protocolo de
Irlanda del Norte El pacto fue alcanzado
por el Primer Ministro del Reino Unido
Ruiz y la presidenta de la comisión
europea Úrsula fonder Legend el nuevo
acuerdo tiene por nombre acuerdo marco
de Windsor y significa el inicio de un
nuevo capítulo en las tensas relaciones
tras el brexit entre la Unión Europea y
el Reino Unido este acuerdo tiene tres
puntos principales el primero es la
creación de líneas rojas y de líneas
verdes para la exportación de mercancías
entre la isla de Gran Bretaña Irlanda
del Norte y la Unión Europea de esta
manera se evita levantar una digamos una
especie de frontera en el mar de Irlanda
ahora se ahorrará tiempo y también queda
completamente eliminada la onerosa
burocracia aduanera y también se elimina
esa de tener una frontera como una
barrera dentro del propio territorio
británico el segundo punto está
relacionado con el futuro cambio de IVA
o de impuestos adicionales que puedan
venir en un futuro los cambios que se
han realizado en el Reino Unido se
aplican inmediatamente en Irlanda del
Norte Por ejemplo también medicamentos
que sean aprobados en el Reino Unido por
añadidura van hasta aprobados y van a
estar disponibles en el territorio de
Irlanda del Norte En tercer lugar este
acuerdo establece el freno de starmont
le dará a las regiones un poco más de
soberanía sobre sus leyes la asamblea
también podrá rechazar leyes de la Unión
Europea para mercancías y también le da
un poco más de garantías a los
británicos de que el tribunal de
justicia de la Unión Europea no es el
único que tiene que resolver disputas
ahora también los ingleses podrán tener
un poco más de margen de acción frente a
este tipo de medidas que ahora entonces
el acuerdo marco de Windsor debe ser
estudiado a profundidad por el
parlamento del Reino Unido y por el
parlamento de la Unión Europea debe ser
respaldado por los legisladores en ambos
lados del Canal de la Mancha para poder
ser puesto en marcha entonces preguntas
que quedan sobre la mesa es esta nueva
versión del protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte mejor que el anterior En qué se
diferencia y en qué beneficia a las
partes marca esto también un nuevo
inicio en esas relaciones entre Londres
y Bruselas de Cara a tener una relación
digamos un poco más cordial porque
estaban bastante tensas y se puede tomar
este acuerdo como un acierto del Primer
Ministro británico Richie sunat es tal
vez su mayor acierto hasta el momento en
lo que lleva de mandato Qué impacto
político tiene este acuerdo pues todas
estas preguntas las vamos a analizar
aquí en el debate de France 24 y para
conversar sobre este tema hemos invitado
a Oscar Guardiola él es escritor y
profesor
University of London él se encuentra
Precisamente en la capital británica y
desde la Ciudad de México aquí un poco
más cerca en el continente americano se
conecta damas o Morales Ramírez
coordinador del centro de estudios
europeos de la facultad de ciencias
políticas de la Universidad Nacional
Autónoma de México ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de este
debate pueden dejar sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales en Twitter en Facebook y en
instagram no se encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta se la recuerdo
numeral el debate f-24 todo junto y a mí
me encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de este programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Oscar Oscar Bienvenido al programa
Gracias por estar con nosotros y para
comenzar este debate creo que es
pertinente conocer las posiciones que
tienen ustedes dos sobre este nuevo
acuerdo en marco de Windsor Cuál es su
opinión Oscar bienvenido
es un placer estar con ustedes y con los
televidentes se trata en efecto de un
logro del Primer Ministro quizás de su
único logro
como jefe de estado ahora bien lo que
falta ahora es un largo camino le va a
tomar varios meses ya se asegura aquí en
el Reino Unido
el aprobar este marco por una parte
porque si bien es cierto que implica
haber llenado los huecos que quedaban En
el anterior protocolo lo que ha
producido es una situación excepcional
para Irlanda del Norte excepcionalidad
que ya ha sido puesta de presente por
otras regiones del Reino Unido Como por
ejemplo Escocia esa contradicción
inherente a este acuerdo que le daría
una posición ventajosa a Irlanda del
Norte respecto de las otras naciones
Reino Unido va sin duda alguna ser un
problema y puede ser un problema
político mayúsculo sobre todo si se toma
en cuenta la posición de Escocia al
mismo tiempo dentro del partido
conservador ahí a quienes no estarían
dispuestos a apoyar a una tan
rápidamente todavía no hemos escuchado
las muy importantes voces de Boris
Johnson o la riach y a falta también
escuchar a los unionistas que han dicho
que se tomarán todo el tiempo que sea
necesario para examinarlas más de cien
páginas del articulado de este protocolo
Así que sí hay una parte un logro Pero
uno al que le queda un largo camino
Claro porque estamos todavía en la mitad
del proceso un acuerdo y este acuerdo
después de esta larga negociación es un
paso pero falta la aprobación faltan
correcciones faltan puntos de vista
estamos a mitad del camino que esto se
ha puesto en marcha Dámaso Bienvenido al
programa Gracias por estar con nosotros
la misma preguntas su opinión sobre lo
acordado entre Bruselas y Londres su
punto de vista sobre este acuerdo marco
de Windsor sí sin lugar a duda Sí es un
avance significativo con respecto al
antiguo régimen que se había negociado
para el brexit pero también en efecto sí
Abre una situación de excepcionalidad de
Irlanda en el sentido de que Pues
básicamente está en ambos lados no Y
esto Pues sí genera situaciones de
índole política de índole jurídica pero
este acuerdo sí es un avance
significativo y sin lugar a dudas
también puede plantear un camino Para
futuras negociaciones de lo que pueda
tener el propio Reino Unido con la Unión
Europea dependiendo de cómo se vaya
afinando el contenido del acuerdo y ya
en la práctica como este se puede llevar
a cabo
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda
la inversa y quiero que entremos en
materia yo daba algunos apuntes básicos
de lo que significa este acuerdo sus
tres puntos principales pero
profundicemos este acuerdo superior
usted lo dice es mucho mejor de lo que
se había logrado en negociaciones
anteriores Por qué desde su opinión
porque la antigua acuerdo efectivamente
este ponía esta Barrera digamos en el
mar de Irlanda y esto desde la visión de
los unionistas efectivamente
debilitaba el vínculo entre Irlanda del
Norte y el resto de la unión y el resto
del Reino Unido las mercancías que eran
exportadas precisamente de Reino Unido a
Irlanda del Norte tenían que pasar por
estas fronteras y esto definitivamente
pues mía en una situación Pues de
debilidad todo el comercio se hacían
largas filas en fin este acuerdo estaría
eliminando precisamente esto y gana dos
elementos por la parte económica se
acelera el comercio se eliminan todas
estas barreras digamos aduaneras
administrativas de revisión y por el
otro lado da un una bocanada de aliento
fresco a los uninionistas para romper
con esta crisis política que tiene a la
asamblea y al gobierno no irlandeses
hace un año para poder de alguna manera
este volverse a poner en el camino y
salir de este embrollo político en el
cual ellos no estaban de acuerdo con el
llamado protocolo de Irlanda de Norte
precisamente por esta situación Entonces
se da un golpe político y también se da
un golpe económico en ambos un doble
golpe entonces de acuerdo a la opinión
de damas o Oscar Cuál es su perspectiva
porque este acuerdo puede ser
considerado superior le dejó esa
pregunta y quiero profundizar en algo
que dijo usted Aquí hay una
excepcionalidad para Irlanda del Norte
Aquí como los norierlandeses pueden
aprovechar este acuerdo que les da pues
prácticamente lo mejor de Los dos mundos
lo mejor de tener comercio con el con la
isla de Gran Bretaña y pues obviamente
siendo parte del Reino Unido pero
también teniendo una estrecha relación
comercial con Irlanda y con el resto del
bloque comunitario
de hecho Santiago la respuesta a ambas
preguntas es la misma tiene que ver con
la excepcionalidad de Irlanda del Norte
en efecto en términos concretos Irlanda
del Norte está en este momento en ambos
lados Como dijo Dámaso hace parte del
Reino Unido y se ha protegido al menos
en términos formales la soberanía del
Reino Unido pero al mismo tiempo Irlanda
del Norte es efectivamente parte de la
Unión Europea o por lo menos del mercado
común europeo
Esto hace que se cree una situación de
excepcionalidad en el sentido en que
Irlanda del Norte va a tener acceso a
ambos mercados algo que no van a tener
niveles ni Escocia ni la propia
Inglaterra y de hecho ya algunos de los
de las voces más
estridentes dentro del
Irlandés
han puesto ese hecho de presente pero
también en Escocia la reacción del
partido nacionalistas escocés ha sido
muy fuerte
su
Vocero ha dicho y es correcto que
a Escocia No solamente la han ignorado
sino que la está la estaría tratando el
gobierno de Londres Como si fuese una
suerte de invitado de piedra a la mesa
puesto que Escocia lo mismo que Irlanda
del Norte votó masivamente por
mantenerse dentro de la Unión Europea y
ahora Irlanda del Norte estaría
digamos recibiendo esa posibilidad su
deseo se estaría realizando pero no así
en el caso de Escocia entonces aquí lo
que estamos viendo Es que ese mismo
punto la excepcionalidad no irlandesa al
mismo tiempo que es una gran ventaja
porque no Irlanda Norte se puede
convertir fácilmente en el sitio de
mayor en el Reino Unido va a ser también
la debido a los contrastes con Escocia
con gales y con Inglaterra un punto de
choque político muy fuerte Lo que sí va
a ser muy interesante por esas razones
Oscar esto Tal vez puede servir como un
modelo de prueba para que otros países
que están dentro del Reino Unido puedan
tener ese tipo de ventajas y también
porque se me ocurre el caso de Gibraltar
que pues es parte del Reino Unido pero
está completamente rodeado por España
que es un país de la Unión Europea este
puede ser un ensayo que puede hacer
aplicado en otros territorios británicos
y porque no en el caso de Escocia Aunque
aquí estamos hablando geográficamente de
un escenario muy distinto Escocia no
tiene frontera con ningún país de la
Unión Europea por lo menos pues en
términos terrestres marítimas tal vez
pero Irlanda es un caso muy particular
este puede ser Tal vez un ensayo y error
de un de un modelo que pueda funcionar a
futuro en otros en otros países incluso
territorios
en efecto lo que acaba de decir me da
para
lanzar una provocación
yo querría predecir a manera de
provocación que en menos de diez años el
resto de las Naciones del Reino Unido
van a pasar a un régimen muy parecido al
que ahora se contempla para Irlanda del
Norte lo que de hecho pondría Reino
Unido en la misma situación en la que se
encontraba o una muy parecida antes de
brexit lo que estamos empezando a ver en
sentido muy lato es una suerte de
reversión del brexit pero sin que lo
parezca Y en ese Y esa es la maestría
digamos de la política británica Así que
es muy posible que este sea en efecto un
modelo para que países puedan volver a
entrar o entrar a la Unión Europea sin
que formalmente lo hagan pero para todos
los efectos concretos
parte de ella claro y ahí queda entonces
la pregunta sobre la mesa de cuál fue el
fin del brexit si se están reversando
las políticas o Cuál fue el motivo que
llevó a este escenario si van a empezar
a buscar la forma de integrarse por lo
menos en la parte comercial y económica
con la Unión Europea damas o qué piensa
usted de este escenario posible que
plantea sí claro en mi primer
participación precisamente había
comentado que este modelo pudiera servir
incluso para la propia para el propio
Reino Unido en su negociación y en su
relación con la Unión Europea porque en
este nuevo acuerdo también hay un
elemento importante que es técnico pero
es Incluso en este carril rojo que son
las mercancías del Reino Unido a la
República de Irlanda pues finalmente se
va a operar bajo un mecanismo de
revisión muy rápida básicamente sobre
los pedimentos comerciales las
declaraciones comerciales y otro tipo de
tecnología permitiría Pues un caso
digamos bastante eficiente de las
mercancías esto de alguna manera nos
está hablando de una facilidad de
tránsito y que en el hecho pues es una
suerte de Libre Mercado este especie
Libre Mercado Incluso en el carril rojo
pudiera irse Estableciendo para el resto
de las otros países que conforman
naciones precisamente Reino Unido y el
propio Reino Unido Sin lugar a dudas hay
un punto importante efectivamente porque
Irlanda pasó de este discurso al menos
de los guionistas de estar en en como
una categoría de segunda respecto a este
proceso de Unión con el Reino Unido a
pasar a una categoría de primera más el
mundo precisamente de la Unión Europea y
no solamente una categoría de primera
sino como bien apunta Oscar a este
estatus de excepcionalidad entonces pasó
de ser el Patito Feo de alguna manera
como ellos menos discu se veían y Ahora
parece ser que están convencidos que
están convertidos en un ave maravillosa
No claro y que no estaban siendo tomados
en cuenta en todas estas negociaciones y
pasaron a ser el punto neurálgico de
todo el acuerdo que bueno así debía
haber sido desde el principio porque era
el punto donde se iban a encontrar estos
flujos comerciales entre las dos entre
los dos bloques Esto me recuerda un poco
como el caso de Noruega que no es Unión
Europea pero tiene unos acuerdos
comerciales profundos con Bruselas pero
también previo al ingreso de países
escandinavos y nórdicos a la Unión
Europea tenía unos acuerdos arancelarios
con Dinamarca con Suecia que son sus
vecinos más cercanos es un poco el mismo
escenario dada esa integración que hay
entre los países escandinavos en
diferentes áreas pasemos al lado
político porque esto claramente tiene
unas consecuencias en el mediano y largo
plazo Oscar ya lo estábamos usted ya lo
estamos aquí mencionando y usted lo lo
estaban diciendo en sus intervenciones
lo que significa esto para Irlanda del
Norte en términos políticos ahora que
están
en el núcleo central en el eje central
de esta discusión aquí políticamente
Cómo se puede sacar provecho
aquí de hecho hay una paradoja muy
interesante
bien puede ser el caso que sea un
gobierno conservador que
tradicionalmente se ha el partido que
tradicionalmente se ha opuesto a el
nacionalismo Irlandés quien termine
dándole una ventaja económica y por lo
tanto también una ventaja política al
nacionalismo Irlandés ahí habría que
recordarlo los televidentes que algo
mucho ha cambiado de la en la política
de la gran Irlanda me refiero a la
República de Irlanda tanto como Irlanda
del Norte los dos países que comparten
como decíamos antes esta frontera en
años recientes cambios demográficos y
políticos han permitido Queen el partido
el partido nacionalista Irlandés que
antes estaba asociado al ejército
republicano Irlandés sea el partido
mayoritario es
casi seguro que va a ocupar el gobierno
en la República de Irlanda y ya tiene la
mayoría en Irlanda del norte de hecho si
stormont estuviese funcionando sería
quien nombraría Primer Ministro los
unionistas que antes eran la mayoría o
un poder dominante están pasando a un
segundo y a un tercer plano Así que el
beneficio político de este acuerdo va a
ser para el nacionalismo Irlandés y aquí
hay una paradoja histórica Porque
todos saben los televidentes recordarán
la larga historia de los llamados
troubles de esa guerra que Tuvo Tuvo
asiento en Irlanda del Norte y que
enfrentó a principalmente los políticos
conservadores de Londres con los
nacionalistas irlandeses Ahora parece
como si paradójicamente se estuviesen
opando los unos a los otros de hecho si
se aprueba tornon Se va se va si el
acuerdo se aprueba el nuevo gobierno al
que daría lugar tendría como líderes a
los nacionalistas Dámaso su opinión
bueno Sí sí sin lugar a dudas es un
escenario bastante complejo pero también
hay que olvidar que este acuerdo es un
triunfo para los unionistas y debemos
recordar que precisamente los guionistas
En este gobierno en la asamblea de
Irlanda del Norte fueron los que
pusieron en jaque desde hace un año en
una inactividad de facto del gobierno
Irlandés precisamente por por estas
demandas que ahora parecieran verse
reflejadas y de entrada es un triunfo
para este partido hay que recordar
también que estos acuerdos de viernes
santo de 1998 abrieron la puerta a la
asamblea propia de Irlanda del Norte y
precisamente a este reacomodo político
entre los nacionalistas efectivamente
con esta idea de las fronteras libres
hacia la República Irlanda y los propios
unionistas con estos vínculos históricos
y que quieren mantener y fortalecer
precisamente con el Reino Unido de hecho
de esta manera se dan los juegos
políticos al interior de la propia
Irlanda del Norte pero también
vinculados con la política nacional y
con el propio parlamento digamos este
del Reino Unido y
por aquí digamos este pues pueden darte
estos acomodos de entrada la lectura
inmediata Pero hay en efecto hay que
tomarla con precaución es que puede ser
un triunfo de los unionistas Pero
entonces si entiendo bien este acuerdo
del marco de Windsor en cierta forma
podría ayudar a brindar aún más estos
acuerdos del viernes Santo consolidar
estos claro son dos acuerdos
completamente diferentes los que estamos
hablando de lo mismo pero podría ayudar
a mejorar la situación en la en Irlanda
del Norte por añadidura digámoslo así
como por golpe y empate de este acuerdo
comercial vendría a blindar aún más esta
relación
Dámaso
en realidad el acuerdo o llamado acuerdo
de Irlanda del Norte blindaba Estos o
honraba y trataban de no tocar
precisamente un asunto tan delicado con
claro como en la relación entre las dos
irlandes derivados precisamente del
acuerdo de viernes santo y lo que hace
el nuevo acuerdo es retomar la misma
lógica pero adicionalmente dar respuesta
a este grupo político de unionistas y
también a políticos de cepadura en el
Reino Unido este para que se pueda
reactivar yo creo que que una de las de
las grandes consecuencias es si se puede
reactivar el gobierno de Irlanda del
Norte importante ese punto Dámaso Oscar
le preguntó ahora por la repercusiones
que esto tiene para el Reino Unido en
general yo creo que la lección Aquí
también para Londres es que
definitivamente Por más que quieran irse
por su cuenta que no quieran ser parte
de la Unión Europea el Reino Unido tiene
que tener una buena relación comercial
política y diplomática con la Unión
europea no solo porque son pesos
evidentes vecinos y no y no fue tan
fácil esa vida de Independencia sobre
todo porque con Estados Unidos nunca se
logró firmar ese acuerdo ambicioso
acuerdo comercial que Supuestamente iba
a reemplazar el mercado de la Unión
Europea y era del que el Reino Unido
prácticamente iba a vivir y ahora vemos
a Londres muy necesitado de estrechar
relaciones con Bruselas con Australia
con Nueva Zelanda que son sus
territorios en el Pacífico históricos
hicieron parte del del gran Imperio
británico y con los que tiene una
excelente relación pero con Estados
Unidos la relación no avanza
has tocado el punto principal y ya antes
lo había sugerido cuando preguntabas
bueno Y para qué fue brexit pues siendo
Francos brexit ha sido un fracaso para
nadie es un secreto que el momento
económico y político
actual de Gran Bretaña es crítico la
economía está en serios problemas de
hecho en este momento hay escasez de de
alimentos en particular vegetales en los
supermercados
hay huelgas hay problemas serios de
carácter económico y aunque por supuesto
el gobierno conservador no podría y no
se atrevería a reconocerlo públicamente
si tienen mucho que ver con el hecho de
que brexit y las promesas que se habían
hecho sobre el brexit nunca se
cumplieron Así que la necesidad de
regresar a esa relación comercial con el
único socio el más cercano el el
francamente geopolíticamente el único
posible era absoluta y ese es
precisamente
el
motivo principal de este acuerdo ahora
bien como apuntaba antes la
excepcionalidad de Irlanda del Norte va
a producir resquemores en las otras
naciones del reino como apunté ya el
partido nacionalista escocés ya hecho
evidente su disgusto con el hecho de que
ha sido tratado como un invitado de
piedra hecho a un lado mientras que
Irlanda se le da este estatuto es
posible que en el futuro esa darle un
tratamiento similar a Escocia puede
hacer la forma de resolver un problema
que es político constitucional y que es
muy grave pero seamos Francos brexit fue
un fracaso y lo que estamos viendo es
precisamente
la confirmación
de ello así esté disfrazada de unionismo
británico Damaso qué piensa usted de esa
posibilidad para Escocia puede ser una
forma de darle un pequeño dulce para
darle un contentillo a ese a ese país
que ya ha mostrado mucho interés en en
independizarse y en ir con un
sentimiento europeo más que un
sentimiento británico más que un
sentimiento Pro Reino Unido
Bueno ya ya también lo había comentado
este a nuestro amigo Oscar Sin lugar a
dudas es cosa pues en efecto nunca votó
a favor del
Escocia ha tenido pues estos
desencuentros ya tuvo un primer
referéndum no logró la mayoría se ha
estado manejando la idea de otro
referéndum el parlamento británico ya
dejó muy claro que esto no va a suceder
y bueno con esto que está pasando con
con Irlanda que consiguió lo que los
propios escoceses han querido y que no
han obtenido Pues yo creo que se abre
una posibilidad pero sin lugar a dudas
va a ser muy complicada y resultado que
ya se dé y las discusiones que se den en
el parlamento del Reino Unido pueden
darnos algunos indicios de Hacia dónde
pudiéramos ver o o caminar hacia otras
regiones como puede ser la la escocesa o
alguna otra no sin lugar a dudas y con
respecto a lo otro que se mencionaba
pues efectivamente el Reino Unido logró
este acuerdo o Macro acuerdo que se
pensaba que los Estados Unidos pero el
Reino Unido Por más que que se hable de
que son una isla y Oscar lo sabe
perfectamente de que uno está en el
Reino Unido está el letrero vaya en
Europa según yo estaba en Europa Pero
bueno no España en Europa pero no son
una isla finalmente están muy integrados
a pesar del brete con la economía de la
Unión Europea y eso es una realidad
tanto para la Unión Europea como para el
Reino Unido y una vez ya pasado los
confrontaciones y los enojos Pues yo
creo que para ambos no solamente para
Reino Unido también para la Unión
Europea deben de Buscar mejores canales
de entendimiento de cooperación y de
comercio sí damas o justamente eso le
quería preguntar porque Oscar Nos daba
la perspectiva británica de de las
lecciones aprendidas Pero esto que
lección le deja también a la Unión
Europea se da cuenta que la importancia
de tener a un Reino Unido cercano como
saberlo llevar dependiendo de las
circunstancias Pero qué elección le deja
Bruselas este brexit estos acuerdos esta
negociación tan difícil y este nuevo
impulso que se le está dando a la
relación con Londres
Amazon Perdón perdón este yo yo creo que
parte de la respuesta está en el en el
nuevo marco de Windsor porque lo que
está obteniendo también es la el
incremento o la recuperación o como se
quiera Llamar de la soberanía de Irlanda
del Norte y uno de los debates que
nosotros hemos visto durante todo este
proceso fue precisamente el de la
soberanía el de las leyes británicas el
que no haya jurisdicción de la corte
europea en territorio británico y todo
esto si se logra esto de la mejor manera
en Irlanda del Norte pues pudiera ser la
salida y la elección precisamente para
la nueva relación esto es Podemos tener
una relación económica y comercial muy
estrecha pero sin lugar a dudas Pues tú
tendes tus leyes tú tienes tu soberanía
tú tienes tus tribunales y es lo que es
parte de la gran demanda de Reino Unido
sí la Unión Europea aceptó ya este
acuerdo el nuevo acuerdo de Windsor y
con esta situación
de ir disminuyendo la reglamentación de
la comunitaria Y pues quiere decir que
ahí hay un camino abierto
interesante ese escenario Oscar Quiero
preguntarle por el curso que le falta a
este acuerdo por tener en los
parlamentos Cómo vive usted allí el
escenario los parlamentarios tienen que
estudiar a profundidad este documento
dar su punto de vista y se espera que
todos estén contentos con lo pactado por
lo menos el Primer Ministro se mostraba
muy positivo en cuanto a esa negociación
el curso en Londres como lo ve usted va
a tener futuro próspera el acuerdo será
votado a favor
dicen los ingleses que el está en
los detalles y hay muchos detalles por
supuesto en un texto de más de cien
páginas con un articulado que está
diseñado de manera
no del todo inequívoca así que lo que se
viene ahora en el parlamento
de Londres va a ser un camino complicado
y tortuoso aquí ya se está diciendo lo
dicen lo dice la prensa británica que
sería cuestión de varios meses y es muy
posible que al Primer Ministro sunak
quien no Es muy fuerte dentro de su
propio partido le sea necesario contar
con los votos de la actual oposición el
partido laborista que también se espera
vaya a ganar va a ganar las elecciones
Próximamente Y eso sí produciría una
reacomodación
muy interesante en el Reino Unido los
significaría que los moderados dentro
del partido conservador
estarían aliándose
sino formalmente al menos de hecho con
el laborismo ahora también moderado muy
de centro y aquí si ese es el caso los
grandes perdedores políticos podrían ser
figuras de el peso del Antiguo Primer
Ministro Boris Johnson claro el camino
va a ser largo tortuoso y nos va a dar
para hablar sobre política británica
muchos meses claramente vamos a tener
varios debates sobre esa negociación
Dámaso y la perspectiva europea también
le doy espacio para que dé su opinión
sobre el escenario en el parlamento
británico pero también dentro de la
Unión Europea allí los parlamentarios
tendrán una un debate fácil cómo lo ve
no también todos los los debates en
órganos donde hay la representación de
todas las corrientes políticas lugar a
dudas este se puede enturdear pero a
largo plazo y Digamos como una mayoría
yo creo que va a ser aceptado porque
sería como el apéndice pero que trata de
mejorar algo que quedó pendiente y que
no estaba dando buenos resultados sería
darle también un aliento político a al
propio Reino Unido a nivel doméstico
pues para que también Avance en otros
temas que son importantes para la Unión
Europea Un gobierno débil tampoco le
interesa a la Unión Europea porque las
negociaciones que se pueden llevar a
cabo pues no están sólidas ni estarían
muy bien fincadas Un gobierno fuerte con
consensos al interior como lo marca
Oscar entre laboristas y conservadores o
de alguna O al menos el partido
mayoritario estaría este dando mejores
resultados pero sí podemos y veremos
seguramente
algunos debates agrios y amargos Pero al
final Yo estoy en una posición positiva
que que esto va a avanzar y los
estaremos analizando con ustedes aquí en
el debate de France 24 damaszo continuó
con usted para preguntarle por la
repercusión que esto tiene para el
Primer Ministro británico veíamos un
Reino Unido muy turbulento con
muchísimos cambios políticos la
inestabilidad en el parlamento en el
liderazgo la muerte de la reina las
dificultades económicas el Coby 19 en
fin hubo un remesón a todo nivel en las
islas británicas esto En qué se puede
repercutir En beneficio del Primer
Ministro es un punto a favor Es un logro
político importante para él ustedes ya
lo mencionaban no tiene incluso mucho
apoyo dentro de su misma formación
política
Cómo calificar esto de Amazon
bueno sin lugar a dudas este pues sí la
la política británica ha estado envuelta
en una serie de situaciones pues que no
han sido buenas noticias efectivamente
lo acabas de resumir muy bien Santiago
con todas estas situaciones la la crisis
económica y la inflación el covid la
situación de Ucrania que también ha
pegado la muerte que también moralmente
para algunas situaciones ha sido
importante y Bueno o sea sabemos que
todo este Torbellino de Teresa May Y
luego el propio Boris Johnson y luego
Trust que fue pues fugaz no su su este
su Primer Ministro como primera ministra
y bueno ahora llega precisamente Richi
sunak como una pequeña bocanada pero hay
un resquebrajamiento del partido
conservador todos estos cambios
todas las políticas de Boris Johnson
estos engaños estas situaciones pues no
han sido flacos Sabores al partido
conservador
en efecto pudieran ganar los laboristas
Pero entonces la gran tarea que tiene
ahorita es una y que la siga haciendo
pues es poner curitas poner banditas
precisamente al partido conservador
recuperar la confianza de los británicos
trabajar para luchar en contra de la
situación económica que realmente está
pegando a los británicos Y esto es un
punto a favor y esto es como una
estrellita que se pone él y que le pueda
ayudar para las los otros temas que No
necesariamente se vinculan con esto es
una primera palmadita en el hombro para
el Primer Ministro por lo menos Ha
logrado un acuerdo ya veremos si esto se
lleva a cabo o no Oscar su opinión
es cierto el Primer Ministro por
supuesto no ha gastado ningún minuto en
darse golpes congratulutorio con
gratolatorios en la espalda Es como
decíamos al comienzo Este programa su
única su único logro habiendo dicho lo
anterior esto no resuelve su debilidad
dentro del partido no resuelve
necesariamente las divisiones del
partido conservador de hecho las puede
ahondar si puede debilitar a Boris
Johnson y a los miembros del ird el
grupo de el llamado grupo de
investigación sobre Europa que son los
recalcitrantes
euroescépticos Pero ellos ya han dicho
el día en la tarde de hoy han dicho que
van a tomarse todo el tiempo que sea
necesario y reunir a su grupo de
abogados etcétera para
[Música]
humillar el acuerdo y allí va a haber
sin duda alguna enfrentamientos fuertes
contra sunak es muy poco probable que es
una
siga siendo o vaya a ser el candidato
conservador cuando lleguen las
elecciones en año y medio
Es un logro pero un logro que puede ser
simplemente temporal pues ya veremos qué
sucede en esta negociación Oscar Damaso
lo Seguiremos comentando aquí en el
debate de France 24 interesante esta
conversación este análisis con ustedes
les agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros en el programa En nombre del
equipo técnico también Les agradecemos a
ustedes la sintonía la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y la producción de invitados estuvo a
cargo de Tania Herrera siga con nosotros
siga con France 24
[Música]